in the midst of failure after failure
and endless scandals and record low
approval ratings Donald Trump is taking
a 17 day vacation to go play golf okay
he is going to his Golf Club in New
Jersey
starting tomorrow according to the
Associated Press this is the guy who
said he'd barely leave the White House
the guy who slammed Obama not only for
taking vacations but specifically for
going golfing Trump is set to spend more
on travel just this year than Obama did
in eight years in office we are told
that part of the reason for this
vacation is the White House is replacing
its heating and cooling system so Trump
just asked to get out of there if the
president wants to do work in Washington
DC they'll find a way for the president
to do work in Washington DC or go to
Camp David or I mean there's many other
many off you go and do work melago even
go to Merrill agressor meanwhile Trump
has told Republican senators many times
cancel your August vacation and stay
until you can get Obamacare repealed not
happening nice idea remember Donald
Trump who previously said quote I would
rarely leave the White House because
there's so much work to be done
quote I would not be a president who
took vacations I would not be a
president who takes time off quote don't
take vacations what's the point if
you're not enjoying your work you're in
the wrong job I'm starting to think some
of those statements might have been wise
and those are the clips that should be
played over and over again at this with
the speaker system at Donald Trump's
golf clubs the leaks could get really
big if there's any maybe silver lining
in Trump taking a 17 day break away from
Washington DC if you are a disaffected
Trump aide Trump staffer and you are
trying to get the word out there that
things are really going poorly there is
no better time to start leaking a whole
bunch of stuff than when Trump is
playing golf 17 days back-to-back I
think that kind of assumes that while
he's in the White House he's watching
over everything and keeping up-to-date
on what's going on not literal room
there no but when the cat's away the
mice will play I mean there certainly
might be a feeling of some more freedom
or maybe even just people being angered
by hey he's taking a 17-day golf
vacation after already playing golf
almost every single weekend yeah I mean
the thing is as president you're never
really on vacation you have that whole
apparatus following you and you can
really do work from anywhere doesn't
have to be the white house well that's
not the issue here what that's not the
issue but with Trump I would argue
you're never really not on vacation he's
kind of always even even in the Oval
Office he's just watching Fox News it
seems like but no you're getting to what
I want to get to which is if you're
thinking Golf is news who cares I don't
care about Trump golfing right I mean
Obama golf to george w bush everybody
golf's right the problem is the
hypocrisy he had endlessly paraded
barack obama for playing golf yet he has
played golf way more often than barack
obama and most importantly he's getting
nothing done taxpayers you are paying
for these golf trips and for bringing
secret service all over the place and
blah blah blah
trump's got nothing done he has
embarrassing public failure after
failure the reputation of the US around
the world is immediately in the toilet
after president obama managed to get it
back up from the doldrums under george w
bush and he's going golfing for
seventeen days on your dime that's the
issue here you know if work-life balance
is important to you which it's important
to all of us we're going to be going on
a vacation soon
sure you should just find a different
job because president of the united
states is not one for you i I think
that's the bottom line right like we did
a story last week which did really well
about Donald Trump jr. is completely
miserable and can't wait for Trump to be
out of out of public office because this
is just not going well for them every
indication that we hear about Trump is
he's reclusive he's miserable he's
watching TV he's just not doing well
whatsoever
Melania can't possibly be happy with
what's going on
you think Kushner is pleased that this
little public service experiment now has
him lawyering up and testifying to
Congress about whether he might have
committed all sorts of crimes
obstruction or even up the treason why
would any of them be happy about this
and Howard Stern actually who I used to
be sort of friendly with chrome Trump
was a regular guest on Howard Stern Show
said that you know Trump is not as far
as he knows isn't talking to his friends
anymore not only Howard Stern but many
others and that it's very hard to
believe that he's enjoying this like why
even get into this well maybe after this
vacay
he'll feel refreshed and rejuvenated
he'll go off the grid not use Twitter as
much and then come back and say well you
know I don't really care about the fake
news media anymore I don't really care
about the Democrats I'm just going to do
my own thing
no more talking about the failing New
York Times maybe that's the other thing
will he tweet during his 17 day golf
vacation I think probably no you will
you can't help it right he can't help
yelling tweets over to whoever is
dictating them for him